et monsieur booba mois
bien
[Applaudissements]
mais on va de l'émission le gars c'est
le conseiller bancaire député coûté
monsieur booba
bora contre mathieu delormeau booba
voici ton poids matthieu delormeau
attention vous devez rester quoi ton
record bras tendu comme ça record il
s'appelle rohff bras tendus est ce qu'on
a vu booba se classer avec civils
assistant vocal de son iphone oui
tu t'es battu tambour comprend et
comprend
série qu'elle a mis en musique de monde
ta mère
attention à ce que vous pouvez pour tous
entraîneurs basques au point vous sent
très souple et merci aux basques au
point bien là près de lui attention
c'est parti bras tendus a donné parquet
soit 2 à top
plus on le voit plus au
bureau le bras
euro le bras
c'est lourd un peu
chez eux
ça va ou pas tu me dis sinon faudrait se
concentrer juste après je crois qui est
un film c'est quoi le film en régie
après
rocha war iii ça va faire un carton mais
pas vu non et ben au bout un ch'ti si on
peut les diffuser
on va voir qui gagnent entre booba et
matthieu delormeau un joueur de moins
souffrir bien raide et la chaux je suis
une structure de leur voix n'est pas
bien les gars son mental
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce que j'aime avec booba c'est son
parcours
parfois compliqué il est tombé il s'est
relevé élevé seule par sa mère je trouve
que c'est un parcours à poigne en ce que
j'aime avec aussi booba c'est le fait
que quand quelqu'un réussit qu'ils
aident les autres inconnus à réussir
c'est très rarement par les sites hockey
au calme a balancé gras du rni ska ou
encore mhd je trouve que c'est rare et
c'est là on va parler de dixon thaler
parce que ça c'est dit que c'est très
fort je vous dis très très fort est ce
qu'on a vu booba offrir vingt mille
euros à son comble à son cambrioleur
pour qu'ils lui rendent ces affaires
décembre dernier tu t'es fait cambrioler
tu étais petit henry sera totale moi ça
va c'est sur l'ordinateur ouais voilà
c'est ça son travail avait des sons tout
ça donc regarder aux montres regardez ce
que booba avait écrit aux cambrioleurs
voilà un job 20000 euros à celui ou
celle qui me rapportera bon laptop et dm
mois d'un faucon pour ana avoila et
regarder en fait ce que tu as fait c'est
que tu as fini la scène on rentre chez
toi
[Musique]
c'est pas beau est ce qu'on a vu booba
s'embrouiller avec son fils pour une
sombre histoire de bananes oui aussi
aussi très drôle
[Musique]
comment ça non
ce tournage je tourne
[Applaudissements]
une pince moi
je
ne partage
pas ces dragages la donne
on va on va quand même appelé charisme
est juste avant booba toi tu es prêt toi
toi tu dis ok surtout sur ce contrat non
c'est un contrat de base ouais je peux
pas être ok surtout tant que lui l'a pas
accepté alors qu'on signe après on se
met d'accord sur le sur la date exacte
etc mais moi je suis prêt à le signer
booba moi je pense un truc je pense que
ce combat ne se fera jamais moi je pense
aussi qu'ils s'y noie pas un c'est sûr
donc non il aurait déjà on aurait trouvé
un compromis voilà tu penses que il
pense aussi que ça se fera jamais donc
j'ai peu d'espoir messieurs donc vous
vous êtes prêts parce que karine va dire
oui mais pourquoi tu le fais pas en
tunisie que tu vas dire pourquoi tu ne
fais pas en suisse non mais tunisie ça
aucun sens et aux réponses et à la
tunisie je sais que c'est mon pays on
s'en fout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai un réseau que c'est contre
moi tu vas combat
carisse on était avec booba voilà où il
avait une proposition à te faire d'un
combat en suisse voilà avec un combat
avec baron vos maltin etc voilà donc on
voulait t'embrasser et du coup booba tu
peux lui dû laisser un message roméo
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on a vu booba charniers le
rappeur la fouine sur son nouveau
dressing ouais regardez
ils m'ont dit tu es ou
dans un magasin de basket à l'origine je
suis dans mon dressing
ils m'ont dit t'es où nous avons
[Musique]
une base et tu dis je voilà je m'en fous
balech je m'en fous balech et il sorte
d'accord un moment voici ton âme à
tous je fume l'émission à mort
jean messieurs bonsoir merci merci
d'être là koné seydou ba oui oui mais
bien
humainement je sais pas mais j'aime pas
savoir quoi honnête moi je n'aime pas
badie le mais je te connais pas et
humainement donc je peux pas t'aider je
peux pas dire si je t'aime ou pas
quoi que vous l'aimez pas proposé n'est
pas toléré de racisme non mais moi ben
alors leurs racines ce qui est dans vos
chansons je le tolère pas vraiment non
quoi comment racines qui votait la haine
anti française la n 1 chez les femmes la
être la haine contre les homosexuels
n'avaient été ce test
allez y les dégâts il est des vérités
qui sont pas bonnes à dire parce que
vous êtes quelque chose à dire à jean
bessière
je peux parler
conviendrez mais là
je reste
aujourd'hui le rap c'est tout ce que
notre société prétend vénéré d'accord
j'ai quelques
merci jours